modern women I think they're
disrespected by women and men to be
honest like I I hear a lot of disrespect
in this space like towards the a you
know calling them broke saying they
don't make enough money when it's like
really none of the influencers could do
what we do without the average men that
build Society in Brun society and you
even said like you know there is still a
large percentage of men that do work in
factories um I think the number one
employment of men in the in the country
is truckers yeah that's true that's the
number one employment of men and it's
like those guys deserve respect and they
add more value to society than women do
in 2023